our main story tonight concerns law
enforcement and specifically the job of
Sheriff that's not to be confused with
Sheriff the proper way to describe Sher
dressed like a cowgirl
that's a sheriff this is a sheriff it's
a key difference you need to learn now
when you hear the word sheriff most of
us have two immediate associations one
at Western lawmen who handled cattle
rustlin and other livestock related
crimes and to Joe Arpaio the infamously
anti-immigrant Sheriff and this next
clip actually includes both a Sheriff
Joe gives an update on a suspect nabbed
through an interesting investigation
finally he decided that he wanted to
travel to Phoenix to meet our undercover
agent and to have sex with his horse
yeah yeah that sounds truly bizarre
until you realize that the horse in
question was this one so you get it
right I mean I'm not saying on a
horse or anything but if you are gonna
a horse it should definitely be
this one now would I travel to Phoenix
to that horse well it depends
doesn't it how much of flights if it's a
$300 round-trip of course not but if
it's a hundred and seventy dollars or
something like that and the hot daddy
horse seemed open to it what definitely
my wife and I have a list of five people
that were allowed to have sex with her
sir
all completely understandable handsome
kind men and miner at that horse five
time so it seems kind of ideal as a
situation anyway sheriff's there are
actually more than 3,000 of them around
the country and generally speaking they
run law enforcement at a county level
cities or towns might have their own
police departments as well but in many
areas sheriff's are the only law
enforcement around and they oversee a
lot of officers around 25 percent of
local law enforcement officers work for
sheriff's that's one in four cops and
depending on where you live your sheriff
might be good bad or a total weirdo and
I will not say which ones are the
weirdos because that would be unfair to
Kenny Boone who until recently was
sheriff in Florence County South
Carolina where he made this incredible
PSA they said
it wouldn't hurt
they said one
one hurts
they lied I'm sheriff Kenny Ben please
please talk to your kids about drugs
talk to your kids about drugs
what are you doing and it's so
magnificently weird
I want 900 more versions of that PSA
where Kenny boon implores to talk to our
kids about other things talk to your
kids about slugs please talk to your
kids about rogues people I'm begging you
to talk to your kids about bugs they
said what lick wouldn't hurt they'll add
the role of Sheriff is a unique position
because sheriff's are actually elected
which means they often produce campaign
ads in fact last year a candidate in
South Carolina produced a frankly
unforgettable ads now you're about to
think that you know where this is going
but you're actually gonna need to brace
yourself for a hard turn I want to tell
you at the start of my campaign some
things that politicians would try to
hide things my opponents may try to use
to tarnish my integrity as a 16 year old
I received a ticket for not having my
driver's license in my possession I've
been in fender benders that were my
fault and about 10 years ago as a young
police officer I attended a law
enforcement Halloween party dressed as
ruthless drug kingpin big Meech Flenory
to disparage your criminal whose actions
hurt our community and country that was
a different time Wow for the record as
well the different time he's talking
about was ten years ago when blackface
was still widely considered and this is
true bad and once in office sheriff's
holds much more power than you may
realize so with over a thousand sheriff
elections this year possibly where you
live we thought tonight might be a good
time to take a look at this job and
let's start with the fact that in most
states sheriff's duties are enshrined in
the state constitution meaning that
their job description can have a certain
old-timey flavor for instance in many
places sheriff's can still technically
form a posse meaning that they can
enlist volunteers to help with tasks
ranging from providing security to
pursuing fugitives and those Posse
members can be basically anyone which is
how this actual school shooting drill
came to include an arguably famous face
this is every parent's worst nightmare
[Music]
these men are learning how to fight the
next school shooter and oddly enough
their coaches 1990s action film legend
Steven Seagal for every second that goes
by I told you this you could have dead
children
yeah that's deputy Steven Seagal I'm
watching Steven Seagal conduct an active
shooter drill while discussing dead
children he's a lot like looking at a
picture of Steven Seagal's current hair
you immediately think to yourself this
is highly unusual and upsettingly dark
still still one of the greatest powers
that sheriffs have is to set law
enforcement priorities in their County
and that in and of itself is not
entirely a bad thing some sheriff's have
advanced genuinely progressive ideas
like D prioritizing low-level drug
offenses or in the case of want Texas
Sheriff fighting hard for bail reform
seventy-five percent our population on
average of the eighty three hundred that
we have is there simply because they're
pretrial detainees and many are just
simply too poor to pay many non violent
offenders I think we need to find a way
to make sure that they could stay with
their families have be held accountable
still but no one can be held
in jail simply because they're too poor
to pay he's right
that's fantastic he's absolutely right
and hearing someone in uniform say that
is genuinely weird but you know a good
weird like like eating a bacon doughnut
or seeing how dogs walk when they wear
shoes for the first time exactly weird
but good and by the way that Sheriff is
not just talk he implemented a site and
release program for low-level offenses
rather than booking people into jails
which is great but obviously sheriffs
can also go hard the other way Sheriff
joke famously prioritized immigration
enforcement to the detriment of other
concerns like investigating sexual
assault and Sheriff Richard Jones in
Butler County Ohio has refused to allow
his deputies to carry narcan to rescue
people mid overdose which is an
incredible policy to adopt in a place
where at one point overdoses were
killing more people than all other
causes of death combined Jones has
argued that it is unsafe for his
officers to help revive people but the
more he talks the less it seems that he
thinks those people are actually worth
reviving at all I'm not advocating that
people die but I'm not advocating that
the police this is their job and I
understand people that say it's a
disease I don't know that I believe it's
a disease
some people will equate it like people
that have cancer and I say it's not
people don't choose to have cancer and
the people with cancer aren't stealing
my air conditions and aren't stealing
the copper out of people's houses and
ripping the wires out look that is
clearly offensive and not just to those
dealing with addiction but to people
with cancer you think that they don't
have the ability to steal copper people
with cancer can grip it rip it and strip
it with the best metal thieves out there
in fact cancer patients have been some
of the best Fivefinger copper shoppers
that I personally know but perhaps the
most significant duty of a sheriff is
that in most places they are the ones
operating the local jail and they can
have a ton of leeway over how to do that
up until just last year in Alabama
sheriff's were legally allowed to
personally pocket any left
the money designated to feed prisoners
giving them a pretty strong incentive to
skimp on inmate food which happened the
most spectacular example of this was
Sheriff Todd enter King of Edo a county
over the years there have been
accusations of problems with the quality
and quantity of food in his jails and
what he denied those allegations two
years ago in most that he bought a seven
hundred and forty thousand dollar beach
house and if that seems like a
suspiciously large purchase for someone
with his salary this probably won't
surprise you over the last three years
the sheriff's food program has run under
budget letting him pocket the leftovers
$750,000 all of it
taxpayer money do you agree that the
optics of this are terrible optics yes
but I can't I can't change the hoc
different optics oh yeah I'd love for
the optics to change here I mean I want
to keep doing what I'm doing though I
just wish it would look better when I
did it joy picked me with sunglasses and
a cool jacket
I think optics better now I like these
better and bad jail conditions obviously
don't stop at food take Sheriff Greg a
Hearn of Alameda County California more
than 40 inmates have died in his jails
in the past five years and at least 29
female inmates have sued Ahern over
conditions and treatment with
allegations ranging from being put in a
cell with feces and blood on the walls
to a woman who says she screamed for
hours as she gave birth alone in an
isolation cell now the sheriff has
defended his facilities and disputed
those allegations though not in a
particularly convincing way when you
hear people say there were species on
the wall blood everywhere and tampon
stuck everywhere is that make you a mean
the people that are in custody for
murder rape robbery who have lied their
entire life and they make things up
literally okay hold on hold on first the
two women who made those claims were not
murderers all robbers they were actually
in there on minor charges all of which
were dropped second even if they were
murderers they should still be treated
humanely and third how do you with on
the question there was feces on the wall
blood everywhere does that make you
angry that is one of the easier
questions to answer well like is
hanck good or is this a horse
the answer is yes
it's obviously yes right look at me yes
at this point you may be wondering how
can shareist be reined in well the
problem there is that that is actually
very difficult while police chiefs can
be hired or fired removing a sheriff
between elections is almost impossible
it generally requires a criminal
conviction intervention from state
government or a recall vote and those
are very rarely successful so sheriffs
operate with a lot of impunity and they
can get pretty belligerent if anyone
questions them remember Kenny boon of
the sheriff who hated drugs but loved
yelling at fake child funerals
well when the county finance director
started asking questions about his
spending boone did not take it well
kevin kenny bone again i don't know what
your deal is but he left for that guy
hey kenny again ignore that last message
i just wanted to say you're a bastard I
don't think you're intelligent I think
you're a nerdy dorky young insightful
individual don't mean I blew it again
ignore this courtroom speech assume talk
to your kids about drugs love you bye
dad damn it Kenny now you should know
we reached out to Kenny moons lawyer
last week and they said that they
dispute the authenticity of that
voicemail you know the one where he says
he's Kenny boon while sounding exactly
like Kenny boo now ideally we'd have
discussed this difference of opinion
with Kenny boon himself but he wasn't
available because fun fact he's in jail
right now
he recently pleaded guilty to felony
embezzlement which actually reminds me
talk to your kids about felony
embezzlement
too often sheriff's are the law wherever
they live and if you're wondering I
don't even know who my Sheriff is do I
have a bad one the very fact that you're
asking that is kind of the problem here
because sheriff elections like most down
ballot elections do not receive nearly
enough attention and often they aren't
even competitive in 2018 59% of all
sheriff races were unopposed in fact
remember sheriff I heard with the
nightmarish out sounding Jail
he's been unopposed for the last four
election cycles as for sheriff no narcan
unless someone steps up to challenge him
he will be unopposed when he runs for
re-election later this year and look
running against an incumbent sheriff is
not easy their own employees are often
loath to take them on fearing
retribution because as you have seen
tonight they're very powerful but that
cannot be allowed to continue
thankfully the same criminal justice
reform movement that's been putting a
spotlight on district attorney's races
is now increasingly focusing on
sheriff's races too and that is not a
moment too soon
because right now we have a position
that has a tremendous amount of
authority with low accountability which
is always an inevitable recipe for
disaster so if there is a sheriff's race
in your area this year now would be an
excellent time to start googling who the
is my Sheriff and learning about
them otherwise you might well wind up
see a campaign ad like this hi I'm Scott
Wilkerson candidate for sheriff it's
been my honor to serve the people of
this county and I hope you'll really as
your sheriff but before my campaign
begins I'd like to tell you some things
other politicians might try to hide I
drink a lot
I often drive while drunk I have what my
therapist calls a hair-trigger temper
like two and as
under man I did work as a Hitler
impersonator at birthday parties
quinceaneras and one disastrous Bat
Mitzvah it was a different time but
that's not all I spent much of the 90s
trying without success to assassinate
that little dog from Frasier I have
dabbled in what you'd call light
cannibalism I've never seen a frog and
not killed it in 2009 I contracted the
h1n1 virus better known as swine flu and
then drove to every sizzler steakhouse
in the state lick my fingers and dip
them in the salad bar why did I do this
well I love sizzler but beyond that I do
not know cannot tell you why whenever
there's a computer in front of me I go
to the Wikipedia page for the Armenian
Genocide and just sort of tone it down a
bit I don't think it didn't happen I
just think people are exaggerating I
came up with the idea for zucchini
noodles in every single hotel room I
have ever stayed in
I have licked the phone ear part and
mouth part that's both parts I give
black people different handshakes than I
do white people whether they want it or
not
what else that's huh oh yeah
I also this horse I think it's
okay because I traveled out of state to
do it wasn't like a local horse or
anything I hoped that would these
confessions I have earned your trust
it's been an honor to serve you as
sheriff for the past 42 years so boat
sheriff Wilkerson when you go to the
polls on November 3rd 2020 it's not like
you have a choice because I'm running
unopposed so see on the streets
I'm dangerous
you